I am a support person to my best friend  who is a Foster carer and I've seen the  value of fostering an adoption there are  thousands of children in this country  who would benefit from having an amazing  loving home and when you look at things  differently this is just my personal  point of view and it's no attack on  anyone here but when you look at the  children that don't actually have a home  and you've got everyone popping out  these babies I get it people say oh I  want I want blood that has to be my  blood my child but if you actually look  into it whether it's adoption or okay  fostering's different for a short time  but adoption it doesn't matter whether  it's blood or not